the flags may be visible but the
community had not always felt so but for
the first time two questions about
sexual orientation and gender identity
were included in last year's census with
results in today giving a snapshot of
LGB plus and trans people across the
country a milestone moment for those who
spend decades campaigning for it
if you aren't counted then you don't
count simply when it comes to making
policy decisions and designing services
so for LGBT plus people to be included
in the census is a truly historic moment
now LGBT plus people are finally part of
that National story and service
providers and politicians have got no
excuse not to listen and to address our
needs
needs like housing Health Care Mental
Health support all in part decided by
census results
and those results show that across the
country Brighton and Hove London and
Cardiff have the most people identifying
as LGB plus overall 89.4 percent of
people age 16 and over identified as
straight or heterosexual with 1.5
percent describing themselves as gay or
lesbian and when it comes to gender
identity 0.5 percent identified as a
gender different to the sex registered
at Birth
the new questions were voluntary but
they were answered by more than 90
percent of people and the hope now is
that policymakers have the tools to
better Target Services across the
country
welcome news for some in the trans
Community who say their access to
treatment like hormone therapy is
lacking the waiting list for any any
sort of appointment for a trans person
in the UK right now is unfathomable it's
awful there's just horror stories on
horror stories about that knowing how
many people are out there that need to
access that
if I'm hoping a wake-up call for someone
who has the power to do some change
and change is with those in this queer
Bookshop in East London are hoping for
despite a dose of skepticism
having accurate data is only useful
insofar as you have organizations and
the government using it that are doing
useful and empathetic and kind things so
um
yeah it's it's its impact is limited but
certainly it will help local councils
and Charities and other organizations to
address their work and to concentrate
and focus their work in more useful ways
ways that can make this data count in
the real world
Sky News